c'est la deuxième journée de
mobilisation pour les salariés de nokia
certains sont venus de lannion dans les
côtes d'armor à paris montparnasse ce
matin ils se sont dirigés ensuite vers
les invalides avant d'atteindre
l'ambassade de finlande mais chemin
faisant ils ont rencontré les salariés
en détresse de sanofi hilarant prêter à
leurs moyens techniques alors une
quelques centaines de personnes ici
ainsi que des élus politiques des
figures syndicale pourquoi sont-ils
regrouper et bien pour se poser au
quatrième plan social de nokia qui
comptent se débarrasser de mille deux
cent trente trois personnes
il y à des personnes visées dans la r&d
principalement dans les sites de lannion
dans les côtes d'armor est également
nausée en essonne les salariés demandent
une annulation pure et simple du plan
social je vous propose les écouter moi
je suis touché parce qu'en fait dans mon
équipe on est on est centre ans on est
deux sens et sur les deux sens et à 139
personnes qui doivent partir on a été
félicité pendant la période de
confinement nous envoie un mail pour me
féliciter de notre rendement nous a dit
qu'ils étaient satisfaits et où on n'a
pas compris ce que ça n'a rien à voir
avec la vie dans le secteur des télécoms
se porte très bien
quatre ans après le rachat d'alcatel par
nokia et les engagements de maintenir
l'emploi et bien quatre ans après c'est
quasiment la fermeture annoncée du site
de lannion
d
et patron de syndicats sont venus
soutenir les salariés aujourd'hui je
vous propose de les écouter
le problème général nous avons plus que
le gouvernement ou des plombs de
cartonner 406 face à la crise
en parallèle de sa et d'entreprises
micro et les sosies de lui et nous
disons que c'est l'argent du bien pour
resservir à maintenir les emplois rares
localités d'industrie en est tout
l'inversé de nokia est en train de jouer
comme des pétroliers parfois joue
cayenne marée noire il en train de
déverser ses cuves pour partie faire
prendre en croyant que ça allait se
passer inaperçu ça ne passera pas
inaperçue la cdt de cet enfer où on est
première organisation dans cette
entreprise
on va le mettre au pied du mur on va
essayer décoller au maximum contre le
mur on leur dira vous devez rendre des
comptes les syndicats s'étonnent puisque
cinq milliards ont été versés en
dividendes aux actionnaires depuis 2016
et puis à l'entreprise nokia a reçu des
crédits d'état alors pourquoi licenciés
aujourd'hui pour une affaire il s'agit
tout simplement d'un plan de
rationalisation pour accroître sa
compétitivité sa rentabilité mais il
faut dire qu'à l'époque du rachat d'
alcatel-lucent 1 dont sont issus les
deux sites dont je parlais et bien la
vente avait été monitorer par par bercy
par emmanuel macron lui-même pour
sauvegarder l'emploi
aujourd'hui bercy a demandé au géant
finlandais de revoir sa copie pour les
syndicats et pour les salariés c'est net
ils ne veulent aucun licenciement
[Musique]